هناك تم انقاذ شخصين تم انقاذ شخصين
يقولوا لهم ابلغونا الان انهم تم انقاذ
شخصين هل نستطيع ان نرى بالكاميرا غسان
لا ادري ان كنا نستطيع ان نرصدهم
بالكاميرا على ايه حال فاطمه في هذه
الحاله يتم اجلائهم سريعا
بسيارات الاسعاف في سيارات الاسعاف ونقلهم
الى اقرب مستشفى لتقديم العلاج اللازم
فاطمه لكن ان صحت هذه الانباء ان هناك
شخصين تم انتشالهم فهذه انباء يعني جيده
وانباء مفرحه
ليس بامكانكم الاقتراب اكثر
يعني سنحاول سنحاول الاقتراب الى ذلك
المكان لكن امنحين بعض الوقت يعني نعم
الان بدات السيارات او تتحرك على اي حال
فاطمه حسب ما فهمنا من
الاشخاص هنا ان سيارات الاسعاف التي تكون
بضوء اخضر تكون مخصصه للجثث اما السيارات
التي تكون بضوء ازرق فهي تكون لاشخاص
ناجين وحالتهم الصحيه متوسطه اما اذا كان
اللون احمر
تكون
الحاله الصحيه لناجي لكنها خطيره وتستدعي
تدخل طبي سريع فبالتالي نحن نشاهد الان
الوان زرقاء لا ادري ان كانت
ون وبصحه متوسطه
الان هم ابلغونا ونحن على الهواء معكم ان
هناك شخصين شخصين تم انتشالهم من تحت
الانقاذ وهم ناجين يعني لكن
لنشاهد كنا نستطيع ان نرصد هذه اللحظه
لحظه اخراجهم
ونتابع هذه الصور المباشره من كاميرا
العربيه في قهرمان مرعش على ما يبدو عمليه
انقاذ وانتشار لشخصين ما زالوا على قيد
الحياه ومفيد العربيه غسان سيؤكد لنا هذه
المعلومات حال تمكنوا من ذلك هذه صور
مباشره نتابعها مع موفد العربيه غسان ابو
لوز ومن كاميرا العربيه كذلك لعمليات
انقاذ تقام الان في قهرمان مرعش في تركيا
ويبدو ان هناك عمليه انتشال لشخصين على ما
يبدو اضواء سيارات الاسعاف تضوي باللون
الازرق مما يعني كما ذكر غسان بانهم احياء
ولكن حالتهم الصحيه متوسطه ويجري الان
نقلهم الى المستشفى بشكل فوري لاسعافهم
الاطمئنان على حالتهم الصحيه ثم انقاذه
شخص واحد حتى الان
حتى الان حتى الان وشب سوري هو من الجنسيه
السوريه تم انقاذه
هكذا فهمنا يعني الانباء ما زالت غير
واضحه تماما تشاهدين ابتسامه يبدو انه
شقيقه او او سنحاول سنحاول التواصل معه
ثلاثه
في جميع الحمد لله الحمد لله رب العالمين
الحمد لله
وحده تسع سنين
يلا الحمد لله على السلامه الله يسلمك
يعني فاطمه يعني لا ادري ماذا اقول في هذه
اللحظات يعني واضح يعني
مشاعر الفرحه والصدمه والذهول يكاد لا
يصدق
هذا الوضع
غسان ماذا ذكر هل قالوا انه هناك ثلاثه
اشخاص تم انقاذهم
تم انتشال فتاتين وبقيت الثالثه لكنهم
اكدوا له ان الثالثه على قيد الحياه